moi je dis ni plus ni moins que
le rôle aussi des révolutionnaires des
marxistes c'est aussi d'être aux côtés
des opprimés et lorsqu'on opprime une
catégorie et notamment je pense aux
femmes qui portent le voile dans ce pays
on essaie de leur faire porter tous les
maux de l'humanité soit disant derrière
une forme d'universalisme des lumières
etc etc etc on a toutes ces nouvelles
figures qui ont
qui sont racisées comme je dis qu'ils
servent aussi de faire valoir à tout un
discours réactionnaire c'est pas
spécialement l'extrême droite qui a
sorti l'islamo gauchisme c'est tout le
secteur autour notamment du printemps
républicain c'est lui qui est ultra
offensif le walkie sme c'est pas
bardella ou
zemmour qui en a parlé le premier le wok
isme c'est ça vient de la bouche des
naulleau ça vient de la bouche de tout
cet cette pseudo gauche qui se
revendique un peu duval 6 mai cetera
comme avait dit valls il ya deux gauches
irréconciliables
il ya la gauche qui
soutient l'islamo gauchisme et nous on
serait la vraie gauche et et ces gens-là
participent aussi à ce discours là
ultraréactionnaire notamment contre les
femmes qui portent le voile
à
[Musique]